[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier sind wieder Mirko Kasimir und
Stefan Netzeband willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland zieht euch warm an für die
heutige Folge egal wo ihr seid selbst
wenn ihr in der Sauna seid denn es geht
um ein eiskalten Mörder wir erzählen
euch die Geschichte von Stefan u und
seinem Opfer Irina u ein Ehemann ihr
habt vielleicht an den abgekürzten
Buchstaben des Nachnamens gehört ein
Ehemann entsorgt seine Frau sorry dass
ich das so Ausdrücke das stimmt aber in
diesem Fall er entsorgt seine Frau im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes weil es für
ihn einfach so bequemer ist eine
unglaubliche Geschichte über einen
habgierigen Mann eine Geschichte die Du
eher im Krimi als im wahren Leben
erwarten würdest doch die Geschichte ist
wahr Irena u die Leiche
[Musik]
wir kennen doch alle Menschen von denen
wir wünschen wir wären in nie begegnet
ja aber klar aber den Mann um den es
heute geht den willst du wirklich nicht
kennenlernen Mirko ich bezogen faul
manipulativ empathielos und ich sagte es
schon ein eiskalter Mörder Stefan u dass
ich in diesem Mann tiefe Abgründe auftun
darüber sprechen wir später noch
Abgründe von den Irina u nichts ahnt als
sie ihren späteren Ehemann kennenlernt
ja Irina u ist eine fröhliche Frau die
mitten im Leben steht sie ist Anfang 40
diszipliniert sparsam und arbeitet hart
als Krankenschwester in einer
Einrichtung für psychisch Kranke
verdient Irina nicht viel Geld dennoch
bringt sie es zu erstaunlichem Wohlstand
für eine Frau in ihrer Position irina
hat im Laufe der Zeit so viel angespart
dass sie sich zwei Immobilien leisten
kann
sie besitzt eine kleine Eigentumswohnung
im Frankfurter Stadtteil Nied und ein
kleines Ferienhaus in Spanien ich glaube
man kann gar nicht genug betonen wie gut
Irina ihre Finanzen im Griff hat und so
eine Frau trifft ausgerechnet auf einen
Mann der gar nichts im Griff hat weder
seine Finanzen noch sein Leben insgesamt
ja das zieht sich wie ein roter Faden
durch seine Biographie Stefan Uhr der
gelernte Fliesenleger aus Westfalen hat
immer wieder finanzielle Probleme und
schon früh zeigt sich dass er diese
Probleme nicht mit Fleisch oder
Disziplin behebt sondern mit einer
gehörigen Portion krimineller Energie
wenn Stefan Geld braucht dann am besten
so schnell und so einfach wie möglich
und so fängt er an zu tricksen er wird
zum chronischen Betrüger völlig schamlos
der Mann Stefan lebt deutlich über
seinen finanziellen Verhältnissen und er
bezahlt am liebsten mit dem Geld anderer
selbst seine eigene Familie wird von ihm
abgezockt Stefan u steht das Sparbuch
seines Bruders erschließt Handyverträge
ab aber nicht unter seinem Namen Luke
betrug Diebstahl und Tricksereien sind
bei ihm an der Tagesordnung es hagelt
Geldstrafen die zuerst seine Eltern
zahlen dann aber irgendwann nicht mehr
und Stefan u landet zum ersten Mal im
Gefängnis
da bleibt er aber nicht lange leider
muss man sagen Stefan u wird entlassen
hat aber gar nichts dazu gelernt von
Reue Demut oder Läuterung keine Spur der
Mann betrügt einfach weiter ja und
erhält einen Job als
gebäudeverantwortlicher bzw Objektleiter
so zumindest ist es in den
rechercheunterlagen zu lesen übersetzt
lautet dieses sperrig klingende
Berufsbild Hausmeister bzw Putzkolonnen
Aufpasser also nichts gegen solche Jobs
das ist ja absolut nichts eher
abschneidendes in so einem Beruf tätig
zu sein aber man muss sagen finanziell
reicht das bei Stefan oh hinten und
vorne wieder nicht und so ist es Ihnen
natürlich super wichtig eine finanziell
bestens ausgestattete Partnerin an
seiner Seite zu haben und die findet er
in Irina u ja erstaunlicherweise schafft
es Stefan immer wieder Frauen an sich zu
binden die sein Leben finanzieren bei
allem Negativen was wir bisher über ihn
gehört haben
muss man konstatieren der kann sehr
charmant sein hat einen Schlag bei
Frauen und er schafft es auch Irina u um
seinen Finger zu wickeln eine Ukrainerin
aus Frankfurt die er über ein
Internetportal kennenlernt und die sich
in ihn verliebt er verliebt sich
scheinbar auch in sie aber in Wahrheit
muss man vermuten liebt er vor allem ihr
gut gefülltes Bankkonto mehr ganz
offensichtlich an der Seite von Irina u
lässt es sich gut aushalten sie zahlt
für die Wohnung sie zahlt für das Handy
für Streaming Abos und das Auto Stefan u
ist weiter verschuldet und lässt sich
durchfüttern Irina u dagegen ist
verliebt und erkennt durch die rosarote
Brille wohl nicht dass dieser Mann vor
allem ihr Geld will sie scheint sich
nicht ausgenutzt zu fühlen schließlich
Leuten bald sogar die Hochzeitsglocken
Irina u geht mit ihrem Stefan dem Bund
der Ehe ein bäh ja beide heiraten und
Stefan nimmt ir muss Nachnamen an doch
die trügerische Harmonie ist nicht von
Dauer im Sommer vor Irinas verschwinden
beginnt die Beziehung zu Krise ein Grund
dafür ist der unerfüllte Kinderwunsch
des Paares beide wollen Nachwuchs doch
weder eine Hormonbehandlung noch eine
künstliche Befruchtung führen zum
gewünschten Erfolg eine andere
Möglichkeit wäre eine Adoption aber die
kommt wegen Stefans Vorstrafen nicht in
Frage also kurz gesagt es läuft nicht in
der Ehe und jetzt spitzen sich die
Ereignisse zu zweieinhalb Monate bevor
Irina auf mysteriöse Weise verschwindet
beginnt Stefan eine Affäre das auch noch
er trifft sich heimlich mit einer Frau
die er auf der Arbeit kennenlernt und
diese Liebesbeziehung beginnt mit einer
Lüge Mirko die geheime neue Frau in
Stefans Leben ist eine 33-jährige
Kubanerin ihr erzählt er dass seine Frau
ihn vor der Hochzeit angelogen habe dass
sie gar keine Kinder wolle dass Wahrheit
verzweifelt versucht haben ein Kind in
die Welt zu setzen diese Tatsache
verschweigt Stefan bei dieser einlüge
bleibt es aber nicht dazu kommen wir
gleich zunächst ein kurzer
Perspektivwechsel denn irina hat
mittlerweile eine Entscheidung getroffen
sie will auf jeden Fall die Trennung ob
sie etwas von der Affäre gewusst hat
darüber können wir nur spekulieren Mirko
aber fest steht sie möchte die Beziehung
beenden und das führt zu Stefans
nächster Lüge es ist eine Art Doppel
Lüge um genau zu sein bei seiner Ehefrau
gibt Stefan zunächst den Kämpfer er sagt
ihr dass er bei ihr bleiben wolle seine
Affäre die mittlerweile von dem
schwanger ist verspricht er ebenfalls
eine gemeinsame Zukunft Stefan lügt ihr
vor seine Frau wolle sich scheiden
lassen und aus der Wohnung ausziehen
mich stört das langsam dass der Stefan
heißt ehrlich gesagt aber anyway da
passt natürlich viel nicht zusammen zwei
Frauen sind jetzt für Stefan eine zuviel
natürlich könnte er seine Frau China
verlassen aber das würde auch bedeuten
er verliert den Zugriff auf die Wohnung
und das Ferienhaus in Spanien will man
auch nicht deshalb schmiedet Stefan
einen Plan einen ziemlich finsteren wie
ihr euch mittlerweile denken könnt im
Oktober 2019 meldet Stefan seine Frau
als vermisst nach außen gibt er den
besorgten Ehemann der sich nicht
erklären kann wo seine geliebte Frau
steckt doch die Ermittler der Polizei
werden schnell misstrauisch schließlich
finden sie Blutspuren in der gemeinsamen
Wohnung Stefan landet am 15 November
2019 in Untersuchungshaft was ist mit
Irina passiert wo steckt sie bislang
gibt es zwar eine vermisste Frau es gibt
Indizien aber keine Leiche aber Mirko
das ändert sich als die Ermittler das
Arbeitsleben von Stefan durchleuchten
und jetzt wird's zugegebenermaßen ein
bisschen gruselig
allerdings die Beamten finden heraus
dass Stefan als Objektleiter eines
großen Gebäudekomplexes die Leerung
eines dort stehenden Müllcontainers
veranlasst hat ungewöhnlich für die
Polizei ist das Grund genug den Weg des
Mülls zu verfolgen und dieser Weg führt
zum Mülldeponie in Flörsheim-Wicker am 7
Januar 2020 suchen Beamte nach den
sterblichen Überresten von Irina u in
einer Halle für Schlacke Aufbereitung
rund 20.000 Tonnen Schlacke werden dafür
abgetragen und die Kommissare haben den
richtigen Riecher es werden drei
knochenrückstände gefunden eine
beckenschaufel ein Oberschenkelknochen
und ein schädelstück der DNA-Abgleich
bestätigt die Vermutung es sind die
Überreste von Irina u
tja und das meinte ich als ich am Anfang
unseres Podcasts gesagt habe dass Stefan
seine Frau entsorgt hat was für eine
grausame Tat wobei bis heute nicht
geklärt ist wie genau Irina ums Leben
kam es gibt aber die Vermutung wonach
Stefan seine Frau in der Nacht vom 23
auf den 24 Oktober 2019 erdrosselt haben
soll dafür spricht der Zeitpunkt der
Vermisstenmeldung und die Leerung des
Containers einen Tag später einen Dienst
dafür nur ein paar Tage vor Irinas Tod
sucht Stefan u im Internet offenbar nach
einer Anleitung wie er seine Frau töten
kann in die Google sucht seine gibt er
die Worte ein mit Schale erdrosseln also
deutet alles darauf hin dass Stefan der
Täter ist und so kommt es zum Prozess im
August 2020 erhebt die
Staatsanwaltschaft Anklage gegen Stefan
u der aber streitet die Tat die
Beweislage ist allerdings erdrückend vor
allem wird im Prozess deutlich welches
Motiv Stefan wohl für den Mord gehabt
hat er fühlte sich gefangen zwischen
zwei Frauen und eine davon wollte er
dringend loswerden ja zu diesem Schluss
kann man kommen wenn man die Nachrichten
liest die Stefan an die beiden Frauen
geschrieben hat es sind eine ganze Menge
in einem Zeitraum von zwei Monaten
spricht Stefan u in mehr als 10.000
Nachrichten an seine Geliebte von Liebe
seiner Frau schickte in dieser Zeit über
2600 Nachrichten auch ihr beteuert er
wieder und wieder seine Liebe was ich
besonders gestört finde an dem Mann ist
Stefan u das wird im Prozess klar will
seiner Geliebten die herzförmige Kette
seiner Frau schenken die er ihr gleich
nach der Ermordung abgenommen hat also
erst bringt er seine Frau um und dann
geht er mit deren Kette zu seiner Affäre
und sagt guck mal schatz was ich schönes
für dich gefunden habe echt Wahnsinn der
Typ diese Kette hat Irina nachweislich
noch bei der Arbeit getragen ein Tag
bevor sie ermordet wird und ich frage
mich wirklich was geht in dem Mann vor
dass der sowas fertig kriegt Stefans
geliebte bestätigt vor Gericht dass er
ihr die Goldkette schenken wollte ebenso
wollte er ihr wohl auch das Handy der
Toten schenken außerdem habe er seine
Affäre versprochen dass sie in die
Wohnung von Irina u einziehen könne also
wirklich wie man im rheinländischen sagt
eine ganz üble Charakter der Typ für den
Staatsanwalt steht fest der vorbestraft
der Stefan u hat Irina u getötet um für
seine schwangere geliebte frei zu sein
und an die Eigentumswohnung seiner
Ehefrau zu kommen am 16 april 2021 fällt
das Urteil Stefan u wird wegen Mordes
aus Habgier zu lebenslange Haft
verknackt
ein zweites Mordmerkmal kann die
Strafkammer nicht feststellen und auch
nicht die besondere Schwere der Schuld
Stefan u könnte also im Jahr 2036 nach
15 Jahren in Haft entlassen werden ein
heftiger Fall und ich habe zum Schluss
noch ein verstörendes Detail muss man
sagen was auch den richterfassungslos
macht Stefan gibt an dass er sich das
Porträt seiner toten Frau tätowieren
lassen will erst töten dann Tätowieren
mit Verlaub ich muss es hier einmal so
deutlich sagen was für ein allerdings
das war die Geschichte von Irina u der
Leiche im Müll wir haben Sie anhand von
Beiträgen der FAZ der Frankfurter
Rundschau von RTL und mit Beiträgen der
bild-regionalredaktion Frankfurt erzählt
danke fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten
Mal euer Mirko und euer Stefan